Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to HunieCam Studio.
Back into the empire! Back to being creepy!
OOOOH HOOOO HOOO HOO HOO HOO HOO!
Okay wow.  That was not how I wanted to start this episode. I apologize for that everybody.
But we're gonna get going on this.
And it's gonna be... REAL good.
Oh shit. It's gonna be - I'm gonna do this full emo mode
because I know that
*cough laugh*
For me to run this empire, my heart needs to be black and dead.
Matt, cut that out. This is embarrasing
OKAY
So we're gonna get back into it
So everyone is doin' their thing
Uh, she just got outta relaxing
And she's gonna make a LOT of money in there
She's making WAYYY more money than she was before
And admittedly, that's good
Because she's rolling into the other...
FFFFFFetishes
Why do I have to say these words?!
Back when it was Huniepop it was just me dating
It was me PATHETICALLY dating!
Now I get NO action!
No love!
And I have to...
just stand on the sidelines and talk about fetishes.
Urgh
Not exactly my ideal scenario
But it's okay
We'lllllll llllllive
See, if I was even smarter I realize now that I shouldn't have even benefited everybody
From, uh
like training for the fashion
Because it was like a waste of time
And nobody actually needed that
So we're gonna just keep her going in there
Wait...
Okay, so, there's actually no one
I belieeeeeve
That has water sports involved
So I'm gonna get rid of the water bah-tle
And then give her more...
"Sugarrrr..."
I'm still trying! My innocence is,
is very delicate right now.
I need to...
I need to cherish it as much as I can.
God dammit, why are they relaxing so much?!
Too many people are relaxing!
We need people on the job!
We need people makin' money!
Looks like Kyanna and Nikki are my main earners right now, which is actually kinda good
Oh! Audrey!
Oh, how are you doing?
Now if you thought Audrey was a...
bitch...
Then you've never met Lillian. Lillian... Wow! Lillian doesn't give a shit about anything.
Lillian is just mean and cold-hearted.
And admittedly, I do need someone from the Goth section of things, with tattoos,
because a lot of the promo that I've been getting has been towards that.
BUT!
That being said.
BUUUUTT! That being said.
Oh, she's got too much in fashion that's right, we don't need that.
But what we do need... Uh, man...
It's either go with the meanie-puss that you know...
Or go with the meanie-puss that you DON'T know...
AND I gotta go with Audrey. She's got a special place in my heart.
She--Oh god Audrey how I missed you!
You are just so delightful.
And see, the funny thing is
I'm kinda assembling a crew of just HuniePop characters aaaaaaand that might be
a little biased to me
I don't knoooow, it's like whatever, ya know
I won't judge if you won't judge but to be honest
*whispers* I kinda like 'em better!
I mean I haven't seen other girls in their non-HuniePop things and---
there's-there's like no Celeste! I don't know why there isn't like Celeste or uhh...
Venus or Momo. There's like none of those characters in this game and I thought there would be
but apparently not! Oh well! What can you do?
Whatever guuuuuuuh...
I forget, what are you-
Oh come on, it's not that big a deal!
Just do your job and then have fun with it, shove this up your butt because you got a stick up there anyway...
So just go on with your life
so that we can live a loooooong time
Without listening to your crap!
Kay, complete.
Good for you.
Get back in there.
EASY PEASY
Who knew it was so easy to be a "let's player"
and do "let's plays" for everyone all around the world.
*scoff cough*
I mean
I wonder, I really wonder
Because... Ok you can make like a channel on websites like
Pornhub and such...
Not that I've ever done it!
But you will oddly find some of my videos on Pornhub.
Like
Oh man...
I forget the title of what it was.
Someone posted like the "Space is So Cool" song and said...
YES.
YEEAH!
YES!!
I'm going to Pornhub *laughter* right now on my phone...
BUT!
NOT... *unintelligible noises* Everybody shut up!
I'm just looking up myself!
on porn- *laughing*
Shut up!
*laughing* That was it!
Oh my god.
Someone--someone posted like something from Mario Maker
And it says, the "Sexy Interracial Man Releases His Anger"
And there's more stuff like that on there.
*sniff*
But anyway...
So yeah...
that's
That's, ummm...
That's on there.
And so, ya know
*laughing*
(still laughing)
In-
"Interracial Sexy Goof Shoves Bread Into His Fury Hole"
What does that even mean!?
Oh man...
Oh my god! And then the space one...
Someone posted the "Space is So Cool" song and said
"Interracial Sexy Freak Is Taken To Infinity and Beyond."
So yeah, that was it.
That's it, yep, that's the one.
Okay, good for me.
Yeeeah sure it is, isn't it?
I know.
Oh man... so yeah that's, that's--that's what you'd expect if you were to go there.
So, yeah... anyway...
I need to get as many items as possible, because right now...
Uh...
Apparently, these "microphones" are very important, we gotta get them...
Gotta get her down on stress, so that she can keep moving forward...
'cuz she's the one that's coked up out of her mind
I mean "sugar"... goddammit
YES! NEW ONES...
That's a lot of money.
Done! Got it! Because I have a lot of money because I'm very good at what I'm doing
SHUT UP!
You have a lot of things you need to do before you can be doing what you need to dooooooo.
Okay, so you-
OH MY GOD! Shut up!
With your stupi- shove this up your butt!
SERIOUSLY!
Now you can make a lot of money!
It's good!
You're suddenly a very good earner...
It's good!!
Um....
Let's see, I've got enough
I've got enough, "micro--microphones..."
Should get more buttplugs! *giggling*
Oh, the day I've been waiting to say that to myself!
OH, I NEED MORE BUTTPLUGS!
The max number of items that you can actually have is...
Three...
So I've got enough of those and I don't think that I-
"YOU'VE GOT A PROBLEM!?"
*yelling unintelligibly*
Okay...
So anyway.
So I'm gonna give this to her as well
Whatever...
Go, go, go, go, go...
Oh shit, we're out of...
We're out of cigarettes!
What the hell happened?!
YEAH! CAKES!
GET THE CAKE FARTS!
Okay you go...
Let's pick up some smokes
Shit...
How many fans does she have--not enough...
Oh shit, she didn't have the basket, that's right!
Why was I-- oh cause she was... Oh! Cause she was moving very faaastly...
Cause--cause now, now Lola is making proper amount of money which is good...
So we just need to diversify everything else that we have and be able to do that...
she's stressed... so she's going in there...
but eventually when she's out, she's gonna get more booooze
because everyone else is getting stressed out of their miiiiiiind.
FAIL?! SHUT UP! I know you're addicted to booze!
Okay so now I just gonna have dedicated someone going into the...
going into the... Just LITERALLY someone's dedicated to always making...
booze runs and cigarettes runs and it looks like Tiffany's gonna be the one for that
so good for her....
What do you have--- HEY BOSS?!  HEY! How ya doin'? Good! Glad...
Okay so we're gonna have Tiffany go in there and you're gonna--- ah destress. Goddammit!
Well gooooood...
...so good.
Okay...
What--what do you have? Okay, sooo... you make good enough money,  that I think...
*frustrated groans*
Nah, I'm gonna kee- ahhhhh
I'll decide later...
I'll deciiiiiiide later....
I gotta get you up to level....
Yeah, level five. The poooooooole
So you...
...too stressed out, dammit...
Well--dammit!
Get outta there!
GET OUTTA THERE!
Everybody's in there... good god.
Okay get in there....
*babbling*
Wow, that is a lot of money
Okay you go---You're suddenly new earner
That's... amazing actually
Oh no! Jessie's out of coke! What are we gonna do...
I don't know
I just need to do this because...
Everyone else is stressed.
The ones who drink and smoke are based entirely off of...
this so they need to be in there. So I'm gonna get her in the strip club.
Yes, go back.
Okay. go there.
Okay you're good there, you destress.
Okay. So...
I think it's about time... we get Beli
because Beli has a lot of fans, baseline anyway,
and she doesn't drink or smoke a lot
which means that WE, are going to have a good ol' time
with her on the team.
Thanks for being here Beli! I'm gonna give you a WHOLE bunch of interesting devices,
and I'm gonna leave it up to you to decide what to do with them
Good? Great.
Cat ears? Very good!
I think...
Oh shit, that wasn't a good one.
Oh no furry's all the way down here, dammit.
Oh the top one was..
bondage..
(quietly) squirti-
Why- I'm just saying these things. It's so weird.
Okay so...
Take that.
"Oh my." I know. It's a little bizarre.
Now I have to determine if anal is up above cake farting.
Okay, cake farting is waaaaay down.
We don't need cake farting up in here.
Shove this up your butt please.
Th-thank you.
Thank you for being so understanding
Ugh.
Now we got the level for rushing
so we may get a lot more done-
I am- I am happy!
I'm very happy! You're very valuable to the teeeaaaam!
(confused noises)
And I kinda have devised an entire roster of just people from HuniePop.
Which is totally cool cause I like 'em a lot.
They're nice people.
"Complete." Good job. Well did.
Oh shit I just sent her there.
Oopsies.
Oopsies poopsies.
Whoopsies poopsies.
Aaaaahhhhhh we need mooooore!
Okay so now Nikki's officially top dog, so she can make SO much MONEY.
Whaaaat?
No moneeeeey?
Suck a cooooock.
Okay.
So now you're done finally.
Maximum capacity at the cam show?
That's horrible.
Okay do you have...?
Yeah you have room for this.
Goddammit you don't have any eeuuuurrgh.
Good to know, I don't care.
I just need to get through this much faster than the duration that I'm doing it.
Goddammit.
More booze!
We demand more booze!
There must be constant influx of boooooze!
And boobs.
Okay so Beli is almost level fiiiiive pole dancing
which means that she's go-
(small burp)
OH GOD I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT CAME FROM, I'M SO SORRY.
WHAAAAA- (unintelligible Mark noises)
Okay. We got more!
Alright.
That...
Thick ass...
Furry...
MILF...
Fit...
Cake farting and fit.
Great.
That's good.
I'm happy.
Euuurrrrrrrrrgh.
Wow, four thousand. Beli, you're doing so we-
Ah shit, I didn-
Ah goddammit I didn't even get her level up.
Aww it's not gonna count nooow,
what an asshole I am.
Goddammit I'm so stupid.
"I DON'T THINK SO."
Fine, whatever, do what you want.
I need to upgrade that.
We need to have- yeah, we need to have five people in a building at once.
Otherwise, we're not gonna be able to do anything.
Okay you need to go... shop.
Okay now the problem is the amounts of money are getting way too high that I'm
not able to do what I need to do.
But this is okay, cause everything is fine.
It's a good problem to have too much money.
It is definitely a good problem to have.
Alright that's good. Okay. So now...
the official problem is not money anymore.
So we need to collaborate on getting everyone up
on the right attitudes.
Which means...
that we need...
to put...
uh...
Okay she already has something up her butt so we don't need to worry about that.
That's totally fine.
But now...
she needs this...
You... no longer have that. You don't need that.
You need to be coked up outta your mind.
Goddammit we don't haaaave that
You look fine, Lola, dear. You are looking delightful.
A little bit of this.
No it's not, shut up.
Okay you get that outta there.
Okay you put...
this... take the cake- oh you're full up.
Yeah I'm feeling fine.
Feeling fine and not stressed at all.
Everything's good.
Ahhhh you go... there.
Yes, very.
Now shut up.
Deeuaaaaaaagh I know.
Oh man, it's starting to get really expensive. Okay this-
This next round just needs to be coordinated so...
we need...
this.
We need...
that.
Teen...
Latina...
Okay and that's good for now.
Alright so now... even- okay.
Now this is the moment that I've been waiting for.
This is why I've been holding out.
Cause, she- Actually no. Would it be better to save these?
Okay I'm just gonna- I'm gonna save these. I'm gonna give her this and she's gonna go in here.
So now, what's happening is we are still doing the exact same thing that we were doing before.
Literally nothing is new.
Nothing at all.
So don't worry about a goddamn thing, we're doing fine.
Nobody panic.
Even though there's obviously no reason to panic. Why would anyone be panicking? It's all cool.
Just get in the cam studio, it's cool.
It's totally fiiiiine.
It's actually a little better to, uh, coordinate everyone to go in the studio at the same time so that you're
able to take advantage of everyone moving up. Because when someone makes money
you have to take the time to be able to get the money out. So it takes more time.
So you gotta, like, stack them on top of each other sometimes.
But that can't happen if you wanna keep everybody moving forward so you do what you caaaaan. It...
makes sense.
Noo! Get back iiiin!
Cause you wanna make- you wanna, like, coordinate it so that the- the easy things...
are done when they're done. Like the easy things keep going...
by themselves because it'll eventually collect the money by themselves...
and you wanna make sure that everything else is kept moving forward
in a veeeery orderly fashion.
Now that's a lot of money that I gotta take outta there.
Gotta invest in this.
Dammit.
This. Dammit.
This. This.
Dammit.
So much munz. So much money.
It's too much of a problem, too much mun.
There we go. Now we got all those for the day.
Then we'll be able to pay everybody else because we're making sO MUCH MONEY.
Okaaaay 'nother buttplug!
I DEMAND IT.
I DEMAND MORE PLUGS OF BUTT.
I shouldn't shout that at the top of my lungs.
I really should be careful about what I'm screaming about.
EEEEEEUUUUUUUGH BUTTPLUGS.
I DEMAND... MORE BUTTPLUGS.
MOOOOOOOORE BUTTPLUUUUUUUGS
I don't know what I'mma do with more bluttplugs. I've got too many buttplugs.
I've got- I've got too many buttplugs. Goddammit, never thought I'd have this problem.
I even got too many things, okay.
So now, okay. HUP.
Everybody hold up for a second. First I'm gonna pay you guys.
Okay so who... has the most fans?
Okay...
Looks like Kyanna has the most fans. Way to go Kyanna! Woooow, niiiice.
Okay but Beli... has the most training.
So I need to get... either Kyanna into training or... actually...
Oooh Jessie...
Okay... alright.
So Jessie- naaaaaaaaw
Yeaaaaaaaa-
Nawwwwww- yeah okay so Jessie...
has an open space. So I'm gonna give her a condom,
she's gonna go into this hotel, "SLEEP," AND DO NOTHING ELSE AND THEN
MYSTERIOUSLY FIND MONEY.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
NOBODY QUESTION IT.
SO DOOOOON'T QUESTION A THING.
SHE'S "SLEEPING," SHE STUMBLED ACROSS MONEY, AND IT'S TOTALLY COOL
EVERYBODY OKAY WITH THAAAAT?
Okay, everything's fine. Don't worry about it.
Okay so I'm gonna keep the last one because I, uh, I actually want to hold off because
late game, it becomes very valuable to hold on to as many condoms as possible for "sleeping" purposes
and finding "mattress money" purposes.
Wink.
Okay but anyway. So now that I got that and I got everything done in an orderly fashion
we were in much better shape than we were.
So I'mma pause it here and end this episode.
Thank you everybody so much for watching. We're doing pretty good.
I don't know if we're doing better than my original run last time, but we're doing pretty good.
So thank you everybody so much for watching...
And as always I will see you... in the next video.
BUH-BYEEEE!